so das superwahljahr fängt super
schlecht an für die cdu
historisch miese ergebnisse in baden
württemberg und rheinland pfalz und dann
fällt die union diese woche in
bundesweiten umfragen auch noch unter 30
prozent
markus söder spricht von einem schlag
ins herz der union ich würde eher von
einem tritt ins gemächt sprechen das
waren nämlich nicht irgendwelche
niederlagen letzten sonntag
weil das so ist braucht es aber zwei
dinge noch einmal diesen sozusagen
diesen wake up call
das ist schon ein break up call a pizza
gestern nur sein backup goalies ist das
für mich irgendwie so jetzt machen wir's
machen wir das die nächsten sechs sieben
monate einfach weiter sein wake up call
ya wake up call before you go go richtig
ruhig wieder hin
29 prozent im bund abgestürzt auf
doppeltes spd niveau wahnsinn nur 24,1
prozent für die cdu in baden württemberg
27,7 prozent in rheinland pfalz das ist
helmut kohl country kohls geistert vor
wut den ganzen bungalow in oggersheim
verwüstet hier der spitzenkandidat
versucht trost zu spenden
euch allen heute abend alles gute haltet
durch seid nicht zu geknickt es ist kein
schöner abend
aber wenn es nur schöne abende gäbe wäre
es ja auch nicht in ordnung ist
natürlich geschmackssache aber mit nur
schönen abenden käme ich ganz gut klar
der mann hat sich wenigstens den kameras
gestellt im gegensatz zu armin laschet
vom neuen cdu chef war den ganzen
wahlsonntag über nix zu sehen und nichts
zu hören
aktuelle umfrage unter wohlgemerkt
cdu-anhängern 72,5 prozent von denen
halten laschet nicht für den richtigen
kanzlerkandidaten
wie will man mit solchen fans eine wahl
gewinnen
wie soll das gehen klar waren mainz und
stuttgart jetzt nicht direkt seine
schuld aber eine hilfe war halt auch
nicht
und das haben wir gefragt in
baden-württemberg und in rheinland-pfalz
war armin laschet hilfreich schadet eher
oder änderte nichts und es ist wirklich
erstaunlich wie parallel das bewertet
wird perfektes wahlplakat armin laschet
der ändert nichts
die union ist in einer fetten sinnkrise
und ich sage kein wunder wenn dein
einziges programm einfach immer weiter
regieren heißt und plötzlich ist eine
regierung in berlin ohne dich möglich
wer bist du dann noch ich sage kopf hoch
kleine cdu jede krise ist auch eine
chance
man muss ja auch gar nicht immer mit
regieren cdu
[Musik]
geben macht doch mal pause cdu nach der
bundestagswahl im herbst schön die seele
baumeln lassen im oppositions resort nur
vorteile
dann werdet ihr zum beispiel auch
endlich nicht mehr belästigt von den
ganzen gierigen lobbyisten die hat man
ja nur an der backe wenn man schon so
lange regiert wie ihr drei unions
bundestagsabgeordnete hat schon erwischt
in der sogenannten masken affäre gestern
abend erst einen weiteren csu mann wegen
dubioser balkan geschäfte und es wird
gegen einen ehemaligen bayerischen
finanzminister ermittelt jetzt könnte
man mit hochdruck endlich an einem
vernünftigen lobbyregister mitarbeiten
oder mit dem finger auf andere zeigen
die müssen einen dann aber auch
einfallen die andern glaube das hat mit
der masken affäre zu tun die eben auch
mit der union ja ich meine die spd hat
ja auch die affäre von von wenn man
sieht da sitzt ein finanzminister
er hat große probleme juristisch hier
die schöne sache mit dem mit dem dings
mit der glatze
der hat ja auch selber scholz und
wirecard wäre richtig gewesen kam aber
nach dem tonsignal es spricht alles für
eine pause cdu wenn man sich die bilanz
der letzten jahre anguckt hat er
offensichtlich keinen bock mehr auf
arbeit bildung rentenreform
digitalisierung lasst ihr alles nur noch
liegen beispiel bei der digitalen
lehrerfortbildung steht deutschland
aktuell auf platz 76 von 78 hinter
moldawien
ich hätte so gerne gegoogelt wo
moldawien liegt aber mein internet ist
zu langsam
ihr müsst ihr erstmal wissen selber als
politiker was passiert da wir sind ja
alle auch nicht in dem internet
aufgewachsen nein du bist damals hinter
dieser großen firewall aufgewachsen
opposition ist keine schande cdu wenn
man müde ist ruhig man gang
zurückschalten
ihr habt ja im gegensatz zu spd und
grünen noch nicht mal ein wahlprogramm
zu stande gekriegt achtung es folgt der
gag des jahres johannes programm kommt
aber sie ist ja logisch dass eine
oppositionspartei immer sozusagen
erstmal überhaupt ein programm auflegt
um wahrgenommen zu werden
eine regierungspartei hat ihr programm
zumindest zu eine zeitlang einfach durch
ihr gutes würden
tue gutes wirken sagte oder meinte
erwürgen da nehme ich alles zurück die
union ist inhaltlich und personell
ausgebrannt zumal ja das politische
berlin nur noch von der sogenannten
ampel spricht ja die ampel macht alle
wuschig vor allem die spd träumt
plötzlich davon den kanzler zu stellen
mit 16 prozent und alle es gibt
mehrheiten diesseits der union dies als
von cdu und csu
es gibt mehrheiten jenseits der union es
gibt mehr heizmöglichkeiten jenseits von
cdu und csu
jenseits jenseits jenseits jenseits
[Musik]
jenseits dieser regierungskonstellation
mit der union genau also comedy
potenzial hätte so eine ampel in jedem
fall über die fdp mit grünen und spd
da implodiert einem das kleinhirn aber
funktioniert das auch inhaltlich in
einem berliner forschungslabor wird
jetzt schon an fdp-abgeordneten getestet
wie gut ihm die parteiprogramme von spd
und grünen vertragen die spd fordert
höhere einkommenssteuer die grünen eine
bürgerversicherung für alle
vermögenssteuer weniger
einfamilienhäuser und zusammen wollen
wir ein ja die ampel vor allem die
grünen werden da keine einfachen
verhandlungspartner seit dem triumph in
baden württemberg können die ja vor
kraft kaum noch laufen mehr als ein
drittel der über 70-jährigen hat in dem
bundesland grün gewählt
die müssen sich ja nicht direkt
umbenennen bündnis 70 die grauen
abgesehen davon können die bundesgrünen
von seinen zahlen natürlich nur träumen
an winfried kretschmann dieser
personifizierten kehrwoche kommen habeck
und berbalk niemals run der winfried hat
nämlich einen entscheidenden vorteil
denken oder kretzschmar ist nicht
schlecht warum
weiter ging's richtig grün ist die
besten grünen sind gar nicht grün
genau wie die union wollen auch die
grünen zwischen ostern und pfingsten
über ihre k-frage reden
robert habeck und annalena baerbock
klären das dann untereinander heißt es
wir schalten wir live zu matthias
matschke
er leitet in berlin die grüne
wahlkampfzentrale herr matschie wie
plant man denn so eine kampagne
wenn man noch gar nicht weiß wer am ende
vorne steht ja das entscheidet ganz
allein unsere wunderbare anna lena
zusammen mit dem dings dem ein hat dem
robert die regeln das und wir probieren
hier so lange schon mal auf verdacht
verschiedene plakatkampagnen aus also
welches farbkonzept passt am besten zur
anna lena welcher slogan steht für anna
lena also wenn es die anna lena wird das
weiß ja noch kein mensch ich habe
neulich bei anne will gelernt dass die
anna lena dass tatsächlich mehr oder
weniger alleine entscheidet wenn
annalena baerbock sagt ich mache das
dann ziehen sie zurück wenn anna lena
berger als frau sagen würde ich mache es
weil ich eine frau bin und die frauen
haben das erste zugriffsrecht dann hat
sie es natürlich wenn sie das als frau
sagen würde
wie soll es denn sonst sagen als
eichhörnchen als doppelhaushälfte meine
sie ist auch eine frau ja aber eben
nicht nur
das ist ja schon wieder dieses blöde
show wie denken wenn sie es wird dann
nur wegen der quote
die frau hat politikwissenschaft und
völkerrecht in london studiert kennt
sich aus mit familienpolitik und
klimaschutz
er ist philosoph und schriftsteller ich
sag das jetzt mal ganz wertfrei jahre
lang habt ihr medien immer nur den
robert angeschmachtet aber jetzt hat
sich der wind offensichtlich gedreht
sollen ab herbst auch im bund in dem
sinne auch von meiner seite herzlichen
glückwunsch an alle spiegel und winfried
kretschmann an dieser stelle aus das
wichtigste ist schon gesagt von annalena
baerbock eben warum soll man sich das
geblubber vom habeck noch weiter antun
also ganz wertfrei gemeint ich weiß
nicht nur ein gefühl aber ich hab den
eindruck ihr habt euch eigentlich schon
entschieden
was so ein blödsinn nur weil wir auf der
grünen homepage die
das quiz geschaltet haben raten sie mit
wer wird kanzlerkandidatin der grünen
annalena b oder b berbalk altes grünes
sprichwort möge der bessere gewinnen
ein witz nichts ist entschieden
gar nichts man muss sich jetzt einfach
in ruhe fragen wer ist näher dran am
bürger
wie kam das an wenn zum beispiel ein
robert habeck demnächst auf
wahlkampfbühne vision entwirft die die
eine quasi osmotische verbindung zur
wirklichkeit herstellt wo die
progressiven kräfte reihen diffundieren
können in die partei wie die energie
aufnehmen können wir aber gleichwohl wie
durch eine membran getrennt sind von
einer reinen bürgerbewegung genau wir
müssen einfach viel mehr rein
diffundieren in die alte membran und wie
geht es jetzt weiter
ja wie gesagt die beiden ziehen sich
nach ostern zurück ins grüne com klar
wird und dann werden ganz sachlich alle
pros und cons auf den tisch gelegt bis
wir eine entscheidung haben und dann
wird es annalena baerbock ja klar
matthias matschke
rheinland pfalz und baden württemberg
der auftakt zum superwahljahr
und auf was für einen wahlkampf dürfen
wir uns da freuen schaaf durchgebraten
oder er blutig die uns deutsche kenne
wird es am ende doch wieder er so medium
trifft sich sehr gut denn hier ist
irgendwer mit medien friedrich
küppersbusch irgendwer mit medien mit
friedrich küppersbusch zum ersten mal
seit gründung dieser republik gehen wir
ohne titelverteidiger in ein
superwahljahr
das gab es zuletzt 49 bei konrad
adenauer der musste sich damals also
noch anders empfehlen und zwar mit einer
reihe pfiffiger erfindungen zum beispiel
der von innen beleuchtete socken stopfen
erfunden von adenauer die cdu begann
also praktisch mit der parole keine
angst vorm socken schuss kann er alte
stopfen
und wo sind die heute diese diese
schrulligen tüftler die die wahren
probleme der menschheit anpacken sehr
früh empfohlen sich da schon ein
gewisser winfried kretschmann letzten
vorschlag gemacht dass man zwei bei der
klospülung spart indem man zum beispiel
eine zwei stufen regelung macht
entsprechenden physiologischen
bedürfnisse darauf kilo klein groß
spielkamerad kretschmann 81 heute ist er
der umjubelte sieger im schwaben kreml
und das hat er natürlich nur geschafft
weil er dieser linie treu blieb und die
anderen schwadronieren rum corona krise
klima aber wenn wir in winfried kümmert
sich um
zinnober roten kelch lächerlich der ist
extrem selten
kretschmann oder wie wir im
internationalen geschäft sagen und weiß
als erfahrener visionär
lieber gut bei merkel clown als schlecht
selber machen sie kennen mich kein
wunder dass wenig konkurrenz sich von
liebsten verstecken wollte andreas stoch
der spitzenkandidat von der spd setzte
bei seiner kampagne vor allem darauf
möglichst nicht erkannt zu werden
ja links der pummelige schweigende
mantel ständer ist kein bisschen darüber
wieso 60er jahre sind stolz aber hinter
dem roten wimpel versteckt doch
natürlich die summe mit der die leute zu
den aussagen zwingt schon auffällig nah
am sonntag bei zwei landtagswahlen
praktisch ein landespolitisches thema
vorkam kaum journalist fragte danach und
die kandidaten selber blieben auch
lieber mehr so im allgemeinen
ich weiß was sie können
die menschen in unserem land wissen
lassen wollen vieles wird harte arbeit
zu hören und austauschen
mit allen menschen junge und alte eltern
die kinder frauen und männer um so mehr
heißt es jetzt nach vorne blicken lassen
sie uns eine gute zukunft für unser land
schaffen
ich arbeite hart dafür dass hier
trotzdem in eine gute zukunft blicken
zu komisch dass eine geile idee wie
kombi auf so was mal drei als letztes
buch heißt du übrigens und ich wünschte
es wäre ein witz die zukunft ist meine
freunde ich habe mir in der achten
klasse auch meine freundin ausgedacht
was normale nächstes mal bei irgendwer
mit medien kretschmann krieg bei markus
lanz liegt doppelte redezeit was man ja
eh nur die hälfte versteht und olaf
scholz veröffentlicht die schonungslose
spd groko bilanz über alles was in den
letzten jahren schiefgelaufen ist
arbeitstitel spd wir wahnsinnig guten
abend
die leute ich wollte euch nur um ein
kleines auto bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut
hallo hast du scheiße fährt haye